it's been a mild winter for many
Americans but you wouldn't know it from
your energy bills due to supply
shortages Amplified by Russia's war on
Ukraine take a look at this natural gas
is estimated to be up almost 29 percent
from the last fiscal year heating oil
about 27 percent and electricity more
than 10 percent Nancy Chen has been
looking into this and joins us with some
tips on how to cut your costs good news
Nancy good morning Dana good morning to
you this is now the second winter in a
row Americans have seen a spike in their
energy bills up nearly 36 percent as
home heating prices have reached a
10-year high so getting rid of those
energy drains lurking in your home could
add up to big bucks
the oil bill it went up 160 dollars per
month per month Bob Duncan and his wife
Allison recently retired but as their
energy bills have spiked the Connecticut
couples had to re-budget their spending
and 401K what do you do in that
situation
we call up our money manager and ask for
more money they also called Chris
Villanueva a house technician who audits
energy use he says air escaping through
window and door cracks alone can cost
homeowners hundreds of dollars a year
what are you testing here so we're
testing here the air leakage from the
house to hopefully help keep the warmer
in the winter now that you have this
going where do you go next now we just
walk through the house checked every
room and see what uh air leaks we find
let's do it plugging leaky windows and
doors and even interior door frames can
prevent heating systems from running
excessively you can put your hand to it
and actually feel the air coming in oh I
do Villanueva also recommends setting
the thermostat between 65 and 68 degrees
switching to LED light bulbs and
improving insulation but some other
energy drain culprits may not be as
obvious known as energy vampires they
could account for up to 20 percent of
your electric bill we always encourage
homeowners to unplug anything that's not
being used 75 percent of Appliance
energy use comes from when they're off
including this coffee maker they have
time uh like a Time on them they're
drawing more current how much can this
all add up to at least 20 30 a month
other surprising sources that together
can cost hundreds of dollars over a year
audio systems like stereos desktop
computers and even cell phone and laptop
chargers not in use instead use a timer
or power plugs you can easily unplug and
when shopping for new appliances look
for the energy star certification these
items typically consume less wattage
which means more savings over the long
run when I hear Bob talk about how much
his energy bill goes up it makes it feel
like you have no power as a homeowner
but this makes it feel like there are
little things that you can do yeah
there's definitely little things that he
can do to help improve it tips to keep
the heat in your home and off your
wallet this winter
now an estimated 6.2 million households
are getting government help with their
energy bills this season that is the
largest one-year increase since 2009.
check state and federal programs if you
need help because through the inflation
reduction act energy efficient upgrades
like switching to a heat pump can give
you a tax credit of up to two thousand
dollars just make sure you save your
receipts nobody likes those big bills
but keeping the thermostat at 65 in your
house could be controversial I mean
speaking as a dad here I like saying put
on a sweater
but some of those tips really good
advice that you wouldn't have thought of
yeah putting some use in my house thank
you for that Nancy good to see you